this is Lucy James reading for writer
Steve Watts even by Nintendo standards
Pokemon has been glacially slow to
change the series has long been
iterative and the community has
certainly taken notice this year's
Pokemon Legends Arceus showed a faint
idea of what a bold reinvention of the
series would look like now Pokemon
scarlet and violet touted by Nintendo as
the first open world RPGs in the Pokemon
series raised the question are these
going to be the main Series games to
follow arceus's blueprint the answer is
mostly no but scarlet and violet still
represent the largest break in the main
series we've ever seen the open world
approach really is impressive in a
Pokemon game especially one as dense
with monsters as this one during a
recent opportunity to go Hands-On with
the games the Pokemon were everywhere
around every corner and roaming freely
around the new paldia region while
setting my site on an objective I would
practically trip over the smaller
creatures initiating a battle
accidentally because I happened to kick
a stray small live and the world feels
open in the truest sense I had a few
objectives in mind for the slice of the
map I was allowed to explore and a
limited amount of time to do it but by
all appearances you really can go any
direction you'd like gone are the narrow
routes of past Pokemon games replaced
with sword and shields wild areas but
applied worldwide the expansive World
means that some major changes have been
made to battling itself and in total
these amount to a de-emphasized approach
to combat on the whole rival trainers
will no longer stop you in your tracks
to initiate a battle presumably because
that mechanic doesn't work in an open
world where you could just go around
them anyway instead you can see if an
NPC is interested in battling and then
you choose whether to initiate a fight
similarly while running into Pokemon
starts a traditional battle you can also
just release your own Pokemon to wander
the world beside you and as they follow
you around they'll independently pick
fights with wild Pokemon these Auto
battles resolve in seconds passively
earning them XP in the process Nintendo
was sure to emphasize that this is less
XP than they'd earned from a traditional
battle so as not to break the game
balance but it's a welcome addition if
you want the freedom to explore the
world without constantly breaking your
concentration for a random battle
despite its appearances this isn't
Arceus you can't catch a Pokemon by
simply sneaking up and tossing a
Pokeball at them and your goal isn't to
collect dozens of produce it does
implement a similar structure though you
can approach a wild Pokemon stealthily
and initiate a battle giving you a
combat Advantage by making your opponent
Pokemon fumble their first turn that
will make capturing Pokemon that much
easier even though it follows a more
traditional structure of occurring in
battle after weakening your opponent
Pokemon and there is a certain wow
factor in being able to freely move the
camera to see your own trainer and
surrounding area from whatever angle
you'd like during the battle with such a
wide open space navigation has also
gotten an overhaul the major additions
are the legendary Pokemon karidan and
Meriden I was playing Scarlet so I had
access to Corydon who acts like a lizard
Mount complete with the ability to scale
walls or Glide this made traversing the
environment a breeze similar to climbing
to a peak and then gliding across the
Vistas in breath of the wild battles do
still initiate when riding on your Mount
though and the camera was positioned in
such a way that corridon's body blocks
your view of smaller Pokemon wandering
around the open world so I would often
run straight into them too quickly to
realize that may just be something to
adjust to in the full game but it kept
me on my toes during the preview session
with my mount in tow I was given the
chance to complete any or all of three
missions for the Three core paths in
Pokemon Scarlet Victory Road the path of
Legends and Starfall Street Victory Road
is the traditional Pokemon Journey that
all experienced trainers know well by
now challenge Gym Leaders to claim their
Badges and ultimately become the Pokemon
champion the path of Legends has you
hunting down monstrously large mutant
Pokemon to research their properties and
Starfall street is a war against team
star a gang of villainous paldia Street
punks I happened to take on the path of
Legends first solving some simple
environmental riddles to locate in what
had to be an intense functional
reference a giant enemy crab I pointed
this out to my Nintendo representatives
and no one left after attacking its weak
point for massive damage it scurried off
and I had to locate it a second time
having defeated it again it escaped
again and I was warned in no uncertain
terms not to follow it there appears to
be more to this questline than we were
allowed to see in this short preview but
that also makes it hard to evaluate how
engaging the path of Legends will be in
practice next I went on to Victory Road
this took place in a traditional Pokemon
Town bustling with activity like Street
vendors and a new open-air Pokemon
Center that could be approached from
either side without entering a building
it was a nice Breezy area to explore and
felt like a welcome break from the
Overworld where Pokemon roamed freely
towns are safe zones and with the Advent
of an open world that feels more
dangerous than ever before the safety
provided here was especially welcome at
least in the mission I played Victory
Road has de-emphasized Combat 2 Pokemon
on games traditionally had you face a
gauntlet of NPC trainers followed by the
gym leader but that has slowly shifted
towards environmental puzzle solving
over the years but still with a few
low-level trainers to conquer in Pokemon
Scarlet I faced the gym leader brassius
without a single trainer battle
beforehand Instead The Artisan challenge
involved a hide and seek game for
sunflower Pokemon once I proved Myself
by catching them and after I took a
quick selfie surrounded by smiling
sentient sunflowers I was allowed to
face off against the gym leader in a
one-on-one bout near the Old Town
windmill the setting made this feel
appropriately homey and as always the
quirky personality of the gym leader was
a highlight of the experience brassius
is a capital A artiste who spoke in
language more flowery than the
sunflowers I had just chased down with
one Mission left to complete I headed
toward the team Star Gate but not before
checking out my food options food and
cooking are an important new element in
Pokemon scarlet and violet similar to
Arceus granting you bonuses to factors
like frequency of finding or catching a
certain type of Pokemon you can buy
pre-made dishes at vendors but you can
also try cooking Yourself by setting up
a picnic anywhere in the wild area this
gives you a place for your Pokemon to
relax and heal up as well as a place for
you to put together a sandwich using
your ingredients I made a horrific
concoction with entire sausages sitting
awkwardly On the Bun since you actually
place the ingredients yourself but it
forgave my taste and gave me a nice set
of bonuses anyway finally ready to take
on teamstar I entered the gates this was
essentially a speed battling challenge
to take down a certain number of their
wandering Pokemon in a set amount of
time but this is where one of the new
mechanics became key I released my own
Pokemon to walk alongside me and let
them initiate the battles passively
racking up winds much more quickly than
if I had manually initiated each battle
individually after completing the
challenge I faced off against the Aries
boss mailer who Strode Atop A souped-up
hot rod that looked like Mad Max meets
minions one element that ran through all
of these mission was the new
terrestrializing ability which gives
your Pokemon a crystalline look and
enhances their powers it essentially
turns your living breathing Pokemon into
little fine Crystal Collectibles though
terrestrial forms can be used to Simply
give your Pokemon a boost you can also
find ones that imbue your Pokemon with a
type outside of their standard abilities
this was extremely helpful in a closed
preview environment where I had a
limited amount of time to build up a
collection of Pokemon so my provided
prefab roster of terrastal monsters was
built to make up for any Elemental
deficiencies but time will tell how it
functions in the full game at the moment
it seems aimed at high level PVP play
letting experienced Pokemon Masters play
mind games with their opponents by
switching to a new type at an unexpected
moment that could be exciting for
Esports but as someone who has never
engaged much with PVP in Pokemon games
it's not something I would expect to use
much myself the terrestal Pokemon are
also the major reward structure in the
final game type we were able to try raid
battles these function at very similarly
to the raid battles in Pokemon sword and
shield albeit with a new timer element
that ticks down as you battle and puts
pressure on your team to complete the
match quickly these battles are tougher
than normal as you'd expect from a raid
but the prices can be the special to
wrestle Pokemon who have affinities
outside of their standard type that
makes them extra valuable and versatile
in ways that go beyond simply super
sizing them as in sword and shield
one unfortunate element that appears to
mirror arceus's open world design is the
appearance of technical shortcomings I
enjoyed arceus's re-envisioning for the
franchise but its visual flaws were
apparent seeming to strain against the
limitations of the Aging switch what I
saw in Scarlet was similarly rough the
aforementioned windmill was an
especially noticeable example as you
could see the individual frames of its
motion instead of moving in a smooth
circular pattern this was a pre-release
demo of course so it's always possible
that game freak will iron out any
technical hiccups before launch but the
hiccups were certainly there even after
an extensive Hands-On with the game I'm
not sure how the mission types and new
open world go anywhere structure will
coalesce into a single cohesive Story
how does the narrative flow when you can
do the missions in essentially any order
along three separate paths do these
disparate plots converge at any point
that wasn't answered during my play time
but I'm very curious to find out and
maybe that's fitting like any good open
world game curiosity appears to be at
the core of Pokemon scarlet and violet
the open world invites exploration and
beckons you to check just around that
Ridge just over that mountain just
behind that River Pokemon scarlet and
violet are still hewing closely to the
Pokemon formula in some key ways but are
shattering the mold in others if it's
successful this will undoubtedly be the
new normal for Pokemon games going
forward and that paradigm shift is an
exciting prospect for more on Pokemon
scarlet and violet make sure to
subscribe to youtube.com Gamespot or
check out gamespot.com